you're in the studio for real
how was that
crazy he don't age he was in miami yeah
he [ __ ] don't yeah he [ __ ] don't i
do but he doesn't
shouts are for real and he cool as hell
like i'm like when they told me he
wanted to work with me i'm like [ __ ]
are you talking about pharrell
it was like yes i'm thinking it's it's
some new producer to call himself real
some [ __ ] what a biter
don't they know there's already a
pharrell [ __ ]
but it was [ __ ] for real i'm like why
do you want to work with me
child
what it's like like when because
pharrell is one of the goats right
and we always hear about it i'm so
intimidated yeah
he plays he's going through beats and
you're like i like this one
he like which one you like and you just
like [ __ ] anyone the [ __ ] give me your
throw away i don't give a [ __ ]
i won't make this [ __ ] work to hell
is perel going to be
anything does he do he have any work on
the project
i think so
so pharrell was on the album i think so
yeah i know some people have been with
him recently and he's been lending some
vocals to them is he did he lend you
some vocals on the record on like a
little bridge maybe like we did like
five songs
one that i'm choosing i'm
we still like 95 you know what i'm
saying but
the one that i'm pretty sure i'm gonna
put on there that he's not on it
but there was ones that you guys cut
that he was on that's fire
blessed what the hell like that [ __ ]
sound crazy for me to even be saying
right now like what yeah
what was there uh can you tell us any
other producers maybe that have made the
cut um
i know you're not going to give me any
features so i'm not even going to ask
but producers maybe
[Music]
let's just say like i i made it a point
to like you know how people be like
focused on the features on the album i
made it a point to be like focused on
the producers on that i'm the production
i want you to be like when you read my
track list you like oh the features and
then you read the [ __ ] track list and
be like oh the producers you know what
i'm saying like
not on some like just do whatever's hot
i want you to be like oh this [ __ ] did
her research this [ __ ] oh she ain't she
from atlanta she was in these [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
you don't you don't see the thought
process in the in a production